Freak bitches,
so it's an issue.
I would,
I would encourage people,
especially maybe people that are prone
to cancer or people who have had cancer
in the past and maybe had treated and
are kind of in a state of remission.
Uh,
if you go,
if you get your body into that,
what we call the metabolic zone where
the level of ketones are higher than the
level of glucose that puts tremendous
metabolic stress on cancer cells or
precancerous cells that have
a huge appetite for glucose.
So and that contribute can,
can initiate autophagy.
So even people who do not have cancer
perhaps don't want to just make sure
they're holding off of it as
a preventative maintenance.
Yup.
And I think it can stimulate almost
purge your body of cancer cells that are
weakened by in this fasted state and also
precancerous cells that may be in the
transition of trends.
You know,
differentiating into this no cancer cells.
These cells are very energy demanding,
especially if they're replicating.
And if you deprive them of energy,
the quote unquote energy crisis
signal that these cells receive can,
can initiate a program cell death
we call Apap ptosis and autophagy.
And that's the benefit of this.
It's almost like housekeeping.
So think about it,
you know,
you accumulate a lot of dead cells that
are kind of sluggish or mitochondria
kind of sluggish,
and then you fast for a
week and it's like reboot.
It's like a setting.
It's like a reset button.
Wow.
Another one was a Norwegian man,
um,
has spent 40 years amassing of,
of a valuable stamp collection
on his bespoke porn film.
Was descent.
His stamp collection to the valley with
three naked porn women would destroy his
stamp collection.
Yeah.
Yes.
There you go.
That's a still from it.
I'm A.
Yeah.
How much does the stamp collection worth?
Well,
live?
it turns out because we
managed to track down stamps,
man.
And he talked to us after
a lot of persuasion.
Uh,
and he's got 10 books of stamps.
Um,
once a year he sends one
to accustom producer.
And so does it.
So that's his thing.
Yeah,
it turns out it's because he grew up
in Iceland where stamp collecting was a
popular hobby at the time in like
the seventies and the eighties.
A stamp collecting was big.
So,
uh,
he became like an
obsessive stamp collector.
The stamps shop owners would say,
Oh,
if you buy the standards
can be Bay valley,
but in 20 years,
but then came the internet
and it killed off the stump.
Is it killed off stamp
collecting as a hobby light?
Yeah,
nerds apparently felt like over
other things to be interested in.
And you know,
the thrill of the chase
just wasn't there anymore.
Like you can easily pack.
Yeah.
So anyway,
so his stamps lost all their value.
The stamp stores closed down,
that kind of collegial atmosphere of
fellow stamp collectors just vanished.
He began to like,
you know,
regret his life choices of like spending
all that time and money collecting
stamps.
He began to feel depressed and isolated.
So he went to see a psychiatrist who
told them that stamp collecting is a
ridiculous hobby
because it isolates him.
So now he pays porn people
to destroy his stamps.
The psychiatrist told them that a
hobby is ridiculous according to him,
and I never talked to the psychiatrist,
but according to him,
yeah,
he said that stamp
collecting is ridiculous.
Hobby
seems like a ridiculous thing
for a psychologist to say.
Sounds bad.
Psychologist enjoys it.
Yeah.
If you're,
if you have all your ducks in a row and
everything's firing on all cylinders,
but you really truly enjoy stamps.
Who's,
who's to tell you there's
something wrong with that?
Well,
the only.
I mean,
one good thing that came out of it was,
um,
he really enriched the imaginations of
the people in the valley and also my
imagination too.
I mean stamps.
But one of the things that I used to
see early on that was so confusing to me
because I came from a striking background
was how many of these guys were
willing to beat the fuck out of each
other in the gym and like that there were
just going to war but not even
going to war with like good skills,
like going to war while there
were learning for the sake of war.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I mean I'm watching them getting
coached and they're beating the shit.
I'm like,
you guys are professionals.
Like this isn't like,
this isn't like some idiots at the y.
uh,
you guys are,
you're supposed to be pros
like you can damage yourself.
The van take years off of your career.
The vast majority of me working
with athletes is doing these very,
very basic things.
Like I'm not,
I'm asking not.
The Guru was like,
oh,
I know the,
the 18 point blood tests and
we're going to get these.
The vast majority of what I do is go,
oh,
okay.
I see the problem here.
Oh,
we need to do this basic thing.
Right?
You haven't eaten a vegetable in a week.
Got It.
Like that as not as much anymore.
But I used to really?
Yeah.
We get a lot of the pro athlete
that doesn't eat vegetables.
We get is honestly,
it's because probably because assholes
like you and they want your show or
something.
I tell people to eat
vegetables all the time.
No they weren't.
They watched this and then like,
okay,
and I'll come at me with a thousand
really weird nutrition questions or
something,
a really weird advanced training ones
because they went to a seminar or
something and I'm like,
back the train up like you're
sparring six times a week.
We've got a whole nother
conversation like,
oh,
we don't do that now.
That's not normal.
Really know,
okay,
or you're doing that or you're
running 35 miles a week.
Got It.
That's the vast majority of what I do is,
is bring these guys back
to life and go like,
let me help you sift through all this
internet stuff that's really complicated
and let's take what's actually good
and bad and dial in a very usable.
So I think
people just get overwhelmed
with options for me.
Internet.
Absolutely.
Because too many people get on exposure
again on shows or platforms and they try
to make sure that,
that they are known as the guy
that knows something different.
Right,
right,
right.
Well,
it's like it's not very excited if
I come up here and tell you like,
oh,
Joel has pros and cons to everything.
Great.
Like,
well that's not fun.
Boom.
And we're live.
Dude.
You survive.
What's up buddy?
Alright,
he survived the Joey Diaz experience.
You know,
I got gotta I got a um,
I got uh,
a text from Tom.
Tom.
Tom,
right?
Yeah.
I said because he asked me,
we were backstage about to go onstage
at the main room and he's like,
I want you to do my podcast,
blah blah blah.
And I'm like awesome.
And then we were texting just about
my schedule with him and then he's.
And then I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to go see Joey Diaz de da.
And he's like,
dude,
fucking gummy bears.
Watch out.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
I didn't like,
I didn't understand what
he was talking about.
Like I didn't,
you know what I mean?
I didn't,
I honestly didn't like,
I was like,
whatever,
I don't what you're talking about.
And then once I got there,
you know,
I smoke weed sometimes,
I don't smoke all the time but
I like to smoke weed sometimes,
but the.
But as far as the edibles,
I like Dean Gelber.
It's given me some pot stuff
but like cookies and shit,
but then like he was eating
these gummy bears and they in,
in a bag and I was like,
going,
fuck,
okay.
And he gave me just like,
uh,
he gave me just like an ear
or some shit and that was it.
And then I was just like talking to them
and then like literally I couldn't talk
anymore.
I couldn't talk part
of it it a half a one,
Scott had to leave.
He's got some that are
like 500 milligrams,
which is just insane.
So you probably had half of that,
which is like 250,
which is fucking insane.
That's an insane amount of weed.
But unless you're an okay,
gee,
yeah,
I,
but I had done mushrooms once before
when I was younger and it felt like that.
Yeah.
Well that's,
Oh,
to the risk of repeating
myself over and over again,
which I do all the time,
but when you eat marijuana,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite.
It's a totally different
psychoactive substance sets,
four to five times more
psychoactive than thc.
So that's why it hits you like that and
that's why people think they got dosed
because when you smoke pot that the,
it's not psychoactive,
but when you eat it,
it's processed by your liver
and something called a one pass.
And uh,
that's how it produces that.
Yeah.
And I can't believe he let me drive home.
Like,
seriously.
I mean I could like.
Because when I was
driving home I was like,
dude,
I got to go.
Like,
I stopped,
I go,
I can't answer your questions.
And then I said let's,
I have to go.
And I left and I drove out and he like,
he let me drive,
like you can understand,
understand Joey Diaz found his mother
dead on the kitchen floor when he was on
acid when he was 13.
He would let you fly a
fucking plane on those things.
He doesn't give a shit.
He's just like,
you'll forget about
cock sucker
anyways.
So when did it hit you?
Like he did a podcast,
like how,
how different do I have?
Fifteen minutes into it
and I couldn't speak.
I had to stop.
I couldn't speak.
So you haven't released the podcast?
I don't know.
I think he did the audio,
but not the video.
Oh,
I told him not to do the video.
I couldn't answer any questions.
Yeah,
but wouldn't that be funny?
I guess.
I don't know.
I'd like to see myself that
fucked up where I can't even talk.